president biden's taking all kinds of
heat ladies and gentlemen after critics
accused the commander-in-chief of having
been too chummy with communist china
biden meeting virtually with chinese
president xi jinping to talk about a ton
of topics from climate to global energy
but they would zip zilch nada on the
origins of kovid19 and whether it leaked
from a lab and despite the fact our
president bizarrely denied his frengie
we're all pals china's leader welcomed
president biden in a very affectionate
manner of course good to see you mr
president and your colleagues it's the
first time for us to meet virtually
although it's not as good as a
face-to-face meeting i'm very happy to
see my old friend so what do you make of
that well i think that he i mean there
they know exactly what they're doing and
so he knows that the president biden has
had to answer several times that uh of
whether
from peter ducey is not just him but a
couple of times well maybe i don't know
at the briefing that happened as well
and repeatedly the white house has said
they are not old friends and so of
course the chinese watch everything that
happens in our media everything that
happens in the briefing room and so he
knew exactly what he was doing and
trolling the president that way i think
that you know what something happened
today that i just was thinking about
my step sign came from scotland today
for the first time in two years wow and
we haven't been able to see him because
of covid and i thought it would be nice
if the president united states would
just show a little anger on behalf of
the world
for what happened and we we just haven't
gotten that i understand that we have to
be competitors and all the strategic
stuff but just
a little bit of fire
wouldn't hurt
a little bit of fighter katie but listen
human rights afghanistan iran north
korea maybe a lot of fire then uh hong
kong tibet uh a free and open
indo-pacific they can't get anything
done with a virtual phone call where
they're gonna get them right i think
probably not nodded out the virtual
meeting looks weak and it's you can't
really have a real conversation with the
president of china in a virtual meeting
but to dana's point i think you know
this is an administration that claims to
care a lot about ending the pandemic but
it doesn't seem like on the surface
they're doing much to prevent the next
one from occurring
china is still
doing gain of function research inside
of not just one lab but many of their
labs
and yet you have the administration not
even showing much care for what happened
last time there's also this big question
of what we do in the next pandemic to
prepare right so a lot of our ppe was in
china when we needed mass gloves all
that stuff and we weren't able to get it
out in supply chain so what are we doing
as a country
to make ourselves more insulated from a
global pandemic and it just doesn't seem
like it's at the top of their
accountability list not just the uh
insulated from
you know the pandemic insulated from
china
glomming up the whole world they're
taking over every place they're they're
beating us in business
our supply our supply chain got
interrupted because well because we put
this back from china we're getting them
back out of there china
their economy peaked 10 years ago
everybody hates them in their own
neighborhood they're probably going to
lash out we just have to avoid some hot
war in the west uh persistent remember
that thought geraldo to dana's point
biden can't get mad at china he's mad at
the written house guys he's mad at the
unvaxxed he's mad at the border patrol
agents where are the bad guys the
russians
where are the bad guys not the guys that
unleash this plague all over the place
i'm with katie a virtual summit is like
a virtual date you're not going to get
anywhere
what you're going to plug in an earpiece
your people are coaching you like
biden's reading a statement he didn't
even write it you can't get at least
pointless
at least there won't be any exchange of
bodily fluids that's a good unfortunate
juxtaposition yes to me
but wait wait wait i got a question when
i was growing up it was all about taiwan
right and there were two little islands
that taiwan owned kamoy and matsu right
off the chinese coast that the chinese
could actually reach with their
artillery
that's
where i think world war iii happened it
could be it could it could we have a
problem with the hologram president i go
back to the the lawyer analogy that i
always use do you want your lawyer in an
important case to be someone who laughs
and gets along with the other side or do
you want a lot lawyer when he walks into
the courtroom everybody goes oh crap
that was trump trump was america's
lawyer we were his client that means he
was disliked by people in china or the
chinese government he was disliked by
the media he didn't care because he was
fighting for himself but
in the same similar alignment he was
also fighting for you then you look over
at this affection this affectionate
showing from china you don't want to see
that right joe's the kind of lawyer who
walks in pat's the opposition on the
back they talk about how that great
cocktail party was they were at that was
a charity for the opera everything was
great when china is happy to see joe in
court right it means they have better
meaner lawyers and they're going to roll
right over him and it is actually i mean
i was going to say what what jesse said
he saves his fire for americans he
really doesn't like us no president
biden yes doesn't like us right the holy
grand president why do you get something
like that because you just watch us what
he says come on he's a he's a patriot
who's worked his whole life
yeah off us he's worked his whole life
off us
and he's not done a damn thing trump is
a macho and i know for macho and that's
why
anyway that's another topic macho will
be my next stop